aí Visitei macho Pit e vi os negócio do
zinka que era os melhores engenheiros da
terra e falava com japonês lá no Mao Pit
japonês perguntando como se eu soubesse
falar japonês
el olhar pro cara fingir que temha
entendido tudo falar assim por ali ó
pode ir é por aqui esse lugar que você
tá é por ali eu aprendi sobre o sol aí
diz que os incas amavam o sol o Deus dos
incas é o sol aí vai constr o templo des
Mat P porque não conhecia Teresina né
que você conhecesse Teresina morava com
Deus os incas era nordestino cara amava
o sol o que que você acha que o sol é
perto do Nordeste que ter o povo Inc E
aí eu vi uns crânios lá no museu que
quanto maior o crânio era para ter
respeito e ser mais importante na tribo
digo pronto porque se cearense viesse do
zinco eu era Rei morei um ano no Ceará
minha cabeça cresceu dois dedos